Ici, chaque semaine, la guerre des zébus
entraîne de nouvelles bavures.
À l'hôpital de la ville, Christian
est venu voir son petit frère.
C'est un jeune berger qui a rencontré
une armée sur les nerfs.
- Ce matin-là, je suis allé tôt
à l'étable pour voir les zébus,
comme tous les jours.
J'ai entendu des gens crier "Dahales" !
J'ai cru que des voleurs arrivaient,
alors, j'ai pris mon arme
et je suis sorti.
En fait, c'étaient des militaires.
Ils m'ont dit : "Jette ton arme !"
C'est ce que j'ai fait, mais après ça,
ils m'ont quand même tiré dessus.
J'ai pris une balle dans la main,
là, juste ici.
Et l'autre, je l'ai prise dans la jambe.
J'espère que je vais m'en sortir.
Mais ici, on nous dit que l'armée
aurait fait bien pire,
que de blesser un enfant.
C'est dans les petits villages aux alentours,
que les militaires ont frappé le plus durement.
Farah a 18 ans.
Elle cherche en vain un vestige
dans les décombres de sa maison.
- Il ne reste plus rien de la maison.
Les militaires ont tout brûlé et volé
tout ce qui avait de la valeur.
Nous découvrons un village entier
que les militaires viennent d'incendier.
Une expédition punitive, sans enquête,
sur la seule foi d'une dénonciation.
Les soldats avaient une liste
de noms de supposés Dahales.
Tous membres de la famille de Farah.
- Les militaires étaient nombreux.
Ils sont passés par là.
Ils ont ordonné à mon frère,
mon neveu et mon cousin,
de s'asseoir contre ce mur.
Alors pour être sûr,
les militaires ont dit :
"C'est quoi le nom du village ?"
"C'est Ampasy".
Puis, ils ont demandé les noms.
Les gens ont donné leur nom.
Alors les militaires se sont mis à tirer.
Mon neveu a pris une balle
dans la poitrine.
Mon frère a pris une première balle
dans la cuisse,
puis, ils lui ont tiré dans le bassin
et une dernière dans la tête.
Les deux sont morts.
Mon cousin s'est évanoui.
Ils ne l'ont pas tué.
Après, les militaires se sont mis
à brûler les maisons une par une.
Tout le village.
Accusé d'avoir volé des zébus,
le frère de Farah,
avait pourtant été disculpé
au tribunal et reconnu innocent.
Mais le soupçon et la volonté de revanche
de l'armée l'ont emporté.
- Je suis triste et en colère !
En tuant mon frère,
les militaires ont tué un innocent.
Il n'était pas Dahale.
C'est lui qui nous nourrissait,
moi et les enfants.
Nous n'avons plus rien
pour vivre maintenant.
Dans ce village calciné,
écrasé de soleil,
le dernier refuge, c'est le grand manguier
et son ombre protectrice.
Les habitants s'y sont réfugiés
autour de leur chef.
- Maintenant, à chaque fois
qu'on entend un bruit de moteur,
on se dit que ça peut être les militaires,
alors on préfère fuir dans la forêt.
Vous savez, avant, notre village
prenait de l'ampleur.
C'était un beau village.
On allait même y installer un marché.
Des populations brisées,
livrées à elles-mêmes.
Ici, la violence de l'État est aussi
aveugle que celle des bandits.
Partout, le manque de moyens
amplifie les erreurs de jugement.
La distance freine sans cesse la vérité
et fait grandir la légende des dahales.
Les voleurs de zébus de Madagascar.